hi welcome to cloud on air live from
Seattle
we host webinars every Tuesday my name
is Morgan MacLean I'm the product
manager for our stackdriver APM products
and today I'm gonna tell you how to make
your apps fast reliable with stackdriver
APM you can ask questions anytime and
we'll do a Q&A session at the end so as
I mentioned we're talking about
stackdriver
APM today it's the tools that we offer
that allow the next wave of service
developers to manage their apps as
reliably and performant ly as we do at
Google stackdriver
APM is composed of three products stack
driver profiler stack driver debugger
and stuck driver trace I'll go and do an
overview of these products in a few
minutes and then we'll do a live demo as
I mentioned before these are the tools
that unlock the same methodologies that
we found at Google for years to our
customers and to the broader market as
you may know Google's being an extremely
large micro-services operator for almost
a decade now and we've developed a lot
of our own methodologies tools and
techniques that we now want to share
with our cloud customers to make them
more successful stackdriver APM can be
used on apps anywhere not just those
running on GCP so you've probably heard
of the stack driver brand before it's
been around for some time particularly
with our monitoring product stack driver
is the suite of tools that we offer to
customers to improve their development
experience on the Google cloud platform
stack driver monitoring is what's most
well known generally it was acquired a
few years ago from a start-up and it's
being brought into Google and it has
stats and dashboards and alerts we also
have stack driver logging and error
reporting which does logs ingestion and
analysis for our customers and can also
highlight logs that appear to be errors
and alert you on those what I'm talking
about is stack driver 8:00 p.m. so these
this is our suite of developer focused
tools it includes distributed tracing
production debugging and continuous
profiling all of which we use at Google
everyday so over the past few years
Google's being a bit of a journey as a
part of its cloud platform initiative
we've made a lot of headway and made a
lot of waves by providing parts of
Google infrastructure to our customers
Google had to advance a number of new
methodologies whether this was high
scale container orchestration or new
storage technologies in order to operate
at extreme scale and we
expose these to customers some some of
these are through open source projects
like kubernetes and Estia where we've
exposed our internal platform or miss
kubernetes and stubby is this do but
others are exposing services through the
through the cloud platform examples of
this include spanner gke and bigquery
and there's many many others the next
sort of pillar of what we've been
providing is allowing customers to
emulate our practices so the most
visible example of this is the site
reliability robots pardon me the site
reliability engineering Bible which we
published a few years ago and there's a
second revision in the works right now I
think it's being published pretty soon
and this allows customers to use the
same sre practices and methodologies
that we've used across our s3 and dev
teams at Google to keep ourselves at
scale finally stackdriver represents the
tools that we offer to customers and so
this is the third pillar that would
allow companies to emulate a lot of the
the infrastructure practices and tools
that we have at Google to operate
incredibly successfully so for the fast
you know 10 20 years developers have
been on a journey if you think back 10
or 15 years ago as a developer if you
started at a new company it wouldn't be
entirely uncommon particularly at
smaller shops if they didn't have some
form of source control or bug tracking
or code review and if you go back a
slightly less amount of time maybe five
or ten years ago for a services company
again it wouldn't be entirely uncommon
if they didn't have some form of
distributed logging or metrics or alerts
it's just those tools were new they were
sometimes expensive and not everywhere
had adopted them yet but today as a
developer if you went to a firm of
almost any size and they didn't have
those your instinct would probably walk
right out the door even if it was on
your first day because everybody in the
industry understands that things like
source control bug tracking metrics
alerting is incredibly important and
it's very it's difficult if not
impossible to become a successful
company without these tools in these
methodologies we believe that
distributed tracing production profiling
and production debugging are the on the
cusp of being this next wave right with
micro services in particular it's it's
distributed tracing is such a powerful
concept and so are the others that
a few years our hypothesis is that it
will be very very difficult to operate
without those and indeed if you look at
companies like Google or others who
operate it similarly high scale and
reliability you'll see that tools like
tracing in particular are very very
common and so it's it's our belief that
this will be this is gonna trickle down
to all companies of all sizes so let's
dig in to the APM sleep the first
component is stack driver trace this is
probably one that at least some of the
viewers will be more familiar with
distributed tracing over the last year
or so has been making a lot of inroads
stack driver trace is a classic
distributed tracing solution and what
that means is that it allows you to view
real customer requests as they come in
to your services and you can view them
as they propagate across different
services so if a request comes into your
front-end service a and propagates the
services B C D and E and so on
a distributed trace captures that it's
incredibly useful for understanding
surface topology so understanding how
those services call each other and
indeed in an incredibly complex
microservices deployment sometimes it
might be the only way that you know that
secondly traces are incredibly powerful
for latency analysis so we use
distributed tracing at Google almost
every day two hundred to understand how
we can make Google calm and our other
services faster and more reliable
the power of a distributed trace is that
not only does it show you the hops that
a request takes but it also shows you
how long it takes at each hop and which
and also which points were paralyzed
versus where you had a bottleneck and so
it's very very powerful when you want to
reduce the latency of a service
particularly tail latency Google has
made a lot of investments in the space
over the years and so you may have heard
of something called dapper Dapper was a
distributed tracing solution that we
created at Google a long time ago we
published a white paper on it I believe
in 2010 and in fact if you look at many
other distributed tracing solutions that
are available in the market many of them
will reference that white papers being
what sort of gave them the idea for it
for building this and we're exposing
dapper to our customers through
stackdriver trace the next is stack
driver profiler this is actually the
newest entrant to our APM sweet stack
driver profiler is a continuous
statistical profiler so it's meant to be
run in production much like our other
tools continually it's not a profiler
that you turn
at certain points and it's not a
profiler that hinders your performance
at all profiling continuous profiling is
very powerful it allows you to
understand the call patterns of your
African production like the actual
function call patterns within your code
as opposed to a trace which shows you
generally service call patterns and it's
very powerful for understanding how much
CPU and memory every function uses if
anyone watching is a Microsoft it's
developer which I imagine many of you
are you know you might understand that
that profiling much like debugging which
we're gonna talk about in a minute is
generally something that you do for
client app development it's very
powerful it's very useful but when
you've moved to web services
particularly micro services it's very
difficult well stack driver profiler we
give you this data and allow you to
discover where where time is being spent
where memory is being spent and so it's
very powerful for general performance
improvements as well as reducing your
costs and we use the same technology
behind this at Google every day across
almost all of our biggest services
finally we have stack driver debugger
which in some ways is probably the most
magical of these three tools stack
driver debugger is a production debugger
that's safe for for use in production
environments with real customer traffic
going through them rather than creating
traditional breakpoints it creates what
we call snapshots which are effectively
breakpoints except they don't halt
execution so you can lay them down in
our very simple IDE like interface that
shows your code when they get triggered
with real customer traffic or if you
trigger them yourselves by mocking a
request they capture the local variables
and the call stack but they don't halt
execution which makes them really really
powerful for root cause analysis
debugger also has another feature called
log points which allows you to add log
statements to your application across
all of its instances in real time so you
don't have to redeploy it so again
really powerful root cause analysis
tools and let's just double click on
these for a second so all of our app all
of these services offer lightweight open
source instrumentation so for tracing
and trap app level metrics our
adjustment ation is done through a
project that we run called open census
that we're collaborating on with a
number of other vendors and open census
provides libraries that you link to your
app that'll capture traces
app level metrics and you can also add
your own information to get sent back to
us
the remaining arm remaining products so
profiler a debugger also have open
source instrumentation it's not part of
open census but they're all open source
on github and we think this is really
powerful for developers because they can
understand how we're actually
interacting if their app if for some
reason they need to make a change to the
instrumentation they can do so and
rebuild it and it's it's really easy to
use because it's tied in to your source
control system so you're not deploying
agents to a VM or updating them there
you're simply typically adding a library
linking a library to your application or
for Java your reference again as a Java
agent you can check and rebuild your app
check in that change and deploy it and
you can you know roll forward and back
between versions fits through source
control so it's really really powerful
and really easy to use for developers we
support a number of languages so on
trace and debugger we support Java go no
js' dotnet Ruby Python and PHP on trace
we also support C++ instrumentation
profiler is quite new so the amount of
interpretation is lower right now we
have support for Java go and nodejs
with and we're building right now and
hopefully it'll shift pretty soon
instrumentation for Python 3 profiler is
free during the beta test period
debugger is currently free and trace is
free up to two and a half million spans
per month which is quite a bit we expect
most customers to stay within the free
tier and so now I'm actually going to
hop to a live demo so what I've done is
I've taken a micro services application
actually developed by weave works called
sock shop and it's available on github
and it's a really useful application for
testing out both monitoring systems and
and micro services deployments and we've
taken this code and we've deployed it to
GK instance and so you can see all of
the services here and sock shops a
really great demo for our products both
because it has I think roughly eight
different services written in different
languages so it's got three Java
services three ghost services and I
think - no js' services but it's also
useful because it wasn't written by us
of you know it's there's always a when
you're a vendor there's always an
incentive to build a demo that works
with your technologies and can show off
your golden path sock shops really power
because it really it emulates a journey
that many of our customers would go on
when they're taking their application
whether it's running on pram or in GCP
and trying to instrument it new
stackdriver
and so it was a great learning
experience for the team but also a great
demonstration for our customers for
demos like this to see how our tools
interact with a code base that might
resemble their own so let's dive into
stackdriver trace this is the main UI
for stackdriver trace we present
captured requests or traces on a
scatterplot style view this is useful
for two reasons first off you can get a
general understanding of the latency
profile of your application from the
scatterplot but secondly it makes it
really easy to acquire traces today our
sampling for traces so we don't trace
every request we trace a certain
percentage of them our sampling is
somewhat random and so generally as a
developer you're going to be interested
in traces that have some kind of unique
characteristic whether that's ones that
have high latency which is what I'm
clicking on in this case or traces that
are correlated with an error or some
other interesting event and a scatter
plot allows makes it really easy to
acquire in particular the high latency
traces and so I'd run a load test
against our shop and you know generated
a very high latency burst of traffic in
fact the latency at some point was up to
40 milliseconds and we can use this this
UI to quickly acquire some traces now
most of these are requests the cart
service which are fairly simple request
goes in something gets added the cart
response goes back but what we'll do is
we'll actually jump to a request made to
the orders endpoint which generates a
really powerful trace because it crosses
a number of services and has some custom
annotations and as you can this is a as
you can see here we have a much more
verbose much more powerful distributed
trace and so we can click through this
and see metadata from each component
these components are called spans you
can understand which spans called each
other verses which are parallel with the
parent-child relationships that we show
here and really importantly you can see
where this trace became actually
distributed rather than just being a
simple trace so you can see while this
trace originated on the orders endpoint
it also hopped to addresses it also then
hopped to the cart service and
eventually went to the shipping service
and so with a classic tracing system you
wouldn't be able to see
this but the distributed trace allows us
to both understand the surface topology
and also where the latency was spent and
so you can imagine as a developer if you
were tasked with speeding up this
service you'd probably start looking
around here at the cart service or
further here down in the shipping
service indeed there's a async call here
that doesn't appear to be actually
running asynchronously and so you might
want to start with that for your latency
analysis investigation next I'm going to
show stack driver debugger so as I
mentioned stack driver debugger is very
similar to a traditional debugging
solution that you may have used
previously whether that's like a you
know a standard interactive debugger and
IntelliJ or Visual Studio except it's
running in production and it's running
across all instances of your app you
don't have to attach it to a single
instance you just open debugger and just
start working and I'm gonna show you
some of the functionality so we have a
function here this is the URL handler
for adding a new item to the cart we're
in the front end service which is
written in nodejs
and what I'm gonna do is just a simple
example I'm gonna lay down a new
snapshot on this line and we're gonna
look for the value of customer ID so if
we go back to we've works and we add an
item or certain until we work its sock
shop and add an item to our cart you can
see it there and we jump to our cart and
we can jump to debug and we can see that
we've now captured the snapshot now in a
real production app with real traffic a
snapshot without many conditions we get
triggered almost instantly that's
because you'd be capturing data from
real customer requests and if you have
concerns about PII we have wastes hiding
that from your developers as well and so
in this in this example we can see that
we've captured my customer ID here and
if I wasn't signed in to the sock trap
demo you'd see an old customer ID
another cool thing that we can do is
copy this we can actually set it as a
condition and we can reapply the
snapshot or apply another one in the
line above and we can rerun the request
and while this doesn't necessarily
generate an interesting example because
of course we know my customer ID it
really shows off how we have similar
tools you can see we captured similar
tools to the deep to traditional
debuggers so we can use custom
conditions and Andy we can use
expressions
to show the values of certain specific
variables that you want to capture and
we also show the call stack here so it's
a really powerful debugging tool you can
imagine for root cause analysis you can
use this to find out both the state of
your system and if certain control flow
state systems aren't working as you
expect the next feature that I want to
show is locked points so log points
allows you as to add log statements to
your application instantly and you can
add conditions or use your own lock just
add a custom statement so what we'll put
here is we're gonna print out the
customer ID so first we're gonna say
on-air webinar and we'll print out the
customer ID we'll apply this and one of
the really nice things about log points
is that it works on app it works with
different logging systems so in this
case we're using stackdriver logging
which as I mentioned before is our
in-house logging solution that we offer
DCP customers but if you were using
another logging solution or just
capturing logs locally I stackdriver
debugger log points would work fine and
it's really really nice so we'll add
this to the cart and that will capture a
log statement and this can take you know
this isn't as immediate as a snapshot
but we start searching through our logs
here so we're gonna say log point and
you can see we captured our log
statement right here and we can view it
inside of the debugger UI so you don't
even have to jump between debugger and
logging it when you're performing these
kinds of investigations it's really
really nice finally we're jumping to
stack driver profiler now I admit this
is a different DCP project we have one
that generates really nice profiles and
it's great for demos so I've switched to
that and the code in this app that we're
profiling is a app it's an application
that constantly zips and unzips of files
so it's it's basically just compressing
and decompressing data continually and
so it generates a really nice flame
graph as opposed to a demo app that gets
very little service what you can see
here is the flame graph that we generate
from capturing those profiles on the
vertical axis you can see the different
names of functions and you can see their
hierarchy so in this case busy
calls busy work once which calls writer
dot right and so on and on the
horizontal axis you can see the amount
of the resource being consumed in this
case we're looking at CPU time but
profiler also supports heap profiling on
languages other than Java we're working
on Java there's some restrictions on JVM
as well as threaded in contention
profiling and as I mentioned before this
is a continuous statistical profiler so
we have effectively no performance
impact on your application it runs
always in the background so you can
capture real data but the way we do this
is by having the profiler agent
generally run on a maximum of one
instance at a time and only take samples
every so often so we'll capture
profiling data for an hour or a day or a
week or longer and then we'll take the
aggregation of that and build this flame
graph so it gives you a really good view
into general system performance so you
can see in this example of a flame graph
if you were a developer who had been
tasked with either improving the
performance of this application or
reducing its cost you'd probably be
interested in this compressor deflate
function and that's because it takes up
a lot of horizontal area just like the
ones above it but it's children don't
and so it has a very high what we call
self time in this case it's consuming
53% of the CPU is being consumed by this
function and not by its children and as
a developer you'd be very very
interested in that now if you know about
compression that you'd probably know
that the flight process will take a
while that might be expected but we've
had customers who had examples were this
was a function they didn't expect it to
be like a regular expression or
something else where they you know a
significant percentage not 50 or
anything like that
was consumed by code that should not
have been consuming that much CPU and as
a developer you can very quickly see
that from the flame graph we had a
number of customers in the Alpha report
that was it was about one out roughly
one hour of work with profiler they
saved about 10% off their bill which is
incredibly powerful and if you can
imagine operating at extremely high
scale like some of these groups it's a
lot of money if you were tasked with
doing a micro optimization or improving
a small part of the system performance
you can also just click on your area
will zoom in and you can then get a
better view of where your CPU time or
memory or other data is being spent so
really really powerful profiler is quite
new we have
some new features that will be coming
out fairly shortly including what we're
calling relieve a name for it yet but
what we're calling sort of weighted
profiling where we're going to give a
higher weight to profiles that are
captured at periods of high CPU or
resource consumption so you can see get
a better view of how your system system
is performing in the worst case as
opposed to the average case and so that
makes it more powerful as a tail latency
as a solution to tack tail latency we
also some integrations that are pending
with stackdriver trace so let's hop back
to our presentation
so to recap off over what we just went
through because I know it was quite a
bit we start we have stackdriver
debugger debugger snapshots and dynamic
log statements remove a lot of steps
from your root cause analysis cycles so
you can imagine that snapshots or laying
down log points would replace your
traditional debugging steps that you
might have today at a lot of companies
when there's a code error what they have
to do is when they don't know where it
is they add log statements to their code
they've then used they then redeploy
their app with with the error is still
in tow because they don't know where it
is and they don't know how to fix it
once the app is redeployed they look at
the telemetry from those log statements
hopefully it tells them where the code
error was or what the problem was but it
might not always and you have to redo
that steps again and again and if you
have a slow deployment cycle that takes
a long time and so debugger produces
this to almost zero right you can you
can use snapshots to find those issues
to find out if certain if statements and
loops are being triggered if things are
not operating the way you expect them to
be without having to redeploy your app
and you can do two across all of the
instances of your apps seamlessly so no
more attaching a debugger no more
testing in a non project production
environment so really really powerful we
use this at Google all the time it's a
pretty magical feature that we wanted to
expose to our customers next we have
profiler
which operates at extreme scale and
isn't limited to analyzing single
transactions one of the biggest uses
that we've seen of customers is both
cost reduction but also finding slow
memory leaks and because it operates
over a long time and because you can
change those time filters by dragging
your view through time you can actually
see if certain functions are now
considering more and more memory which
would imply that there's a leak there we
have a number of new
features coming to profile throughout
the RET profiler throughout the rest of
the year
and we're really excited to see where it
goes finally we stack driver trace
tracing distributed tracing for the last
few years has become generally better
understood by a lot of our customers and
indeed the industry at large but tracing
tools tend to be either expensive or
difficult to adopt there are some open
source solutions to the space generally
deploying your own can be quite
challenging and a lot of the page
solutions are quite costly a stack
driver trace isn't it's easy to get
started with for most customers it's
effectively free and it can give you
deep insight into how your service
topology works and also into late how to
reduce latency of your application I
want to touch on instrumentation one
more time so all of our instrumentation
is apache licensed and open source and
it's on github all of it we generally
not always in the case of debugger
because it's not quite that's useful but
we generally expose api's the developers
can use to capture your custom data and
what I mean by that is for tracing you
can create your own spans you can add
annotations to spans so in the demo that
I just did some of those spans didn't
necessarily represent our pcs or
requests that went to other services
they were rather created by the
developer to track what they thought
were long running processes and for for
a profiler we also similarly have api's
that you can use to capture custom data
for debugger on some languages we have
api's of allow you to arbitrarily
capture snapshot our traces and app
level metrics are captured by a project
that we call open census that we're
collaborating on with other vendors open
census effectively automatically
captures traces allows you to annotate
them captures app level metrics and then
will send them to the back end of your
choice stackdriver is one of those
backends but we also support for me Thea
sip can and a number of others we did I
mentioned that we had a alpha test to
stack driver profiler and so one of the
the groups that join the alpha test with
us was snapchat and so they had a lot of
success with profiler they were able to
find areas in their code where they they
had been consuming more CPU than they
expected so it was performing more
slowly or costing more money than they
had desired and they use profiler to
both highlight those because they didn't
know about them
and also to then optimize them and so
they were happy enough that they
provided us with a nice quote that I'm
able to share with you here but Snap was
certainly not the only participants in
itself I know at Google the GCP we like
to talk about snapchat a lot in
particular we had a number of companies
and as I mentioned before we heard from
a number of customers that they with it
with roughly one hour of time they were
able to save about 10% off of their bill
so let's sort of summarize what we've
talked about so stackdriver APM is an
essential tool kit for the next wave of
developers it unlocks the methodologies
and the tools and techniques that we've
used at Google over the past decade to
operate at extreme scale and a ship code
safely and quickly and it provides these
to customers around the world these
customers might be running on GCP they
might be running on Prem they might not
even use some of our services and that's
okay we want them to use stackdriver APM
and we're really excited and really
proud of the functionality that provides
developers can use the these tools on on
generally on web services but also on on
other things or slow running processes
and it really is going to just provide a
lot of insight and a lot of confidence I
think to engineering organizations about
their ability to understand what their
service is doing and their ability to
ship code rapidly as I mentioned before
it works on services hosted anywhere
whether that's any other cloud or
on-premises and we're we're pretty
excited about it
all right so that wraps up the
presentation we're gonna have hop to Q&A
in a few minutes thank you very much
you
all right we're back so we gathered some
questions from the audience I'm gonna
answer these the first question is can
ID bug nodejs or angular code running on
my local machine like my laptop how can
different reports helpfully
understanding of issues so I'm gonna
guess that by debug you mean stackdriver
debugger and yes you can use it CD to
debug code that's running locally or
anywhere else we've used it both
internally at Google and other places
where in fact the instrumentation is
running on someone's laptop one of the
other things that I forgot to mention
during the demo is that you can also to
view the source code you have to pull it
in from another source sort of syncing
it from another source to pull it in and
so if your code is stored on github on
on bitbucket on github enterprise on git
lab or the Google Cloud repositories you
can just use your credentials to
automatically make the show of the code
show up in stackdriver debugger the
other thing you can do for this laptop
debugging scenario where you might not
want to be storing the code elsewhere
because you're just doing something
simply locally is you can and if we can
just come to my cut to my screen in the
debugger you can go to the add source
code UI you can actually select local
files and what this allows you do is
actually pull in source code that's
stored locally from your machine this is
useful for the at local debugging
scenario that you're asking about but
this is also useful when you've made
edits and better running elsewhere not
on your primary service and or when you
know the exact version of code that's
being deployed and you want to debug it
see you're not forced to pull it in
through github or other sources another
interesting thing about this feature is
that we actually don't save your code to
Google
it simply syncs locally to your browser
never gets sent to us and so if you have
any security concerns or concerns about
Google accessing your code you don't
need to worry it's all pulled in just
locally to your browser ever gets
transmitted the next question is about
profiler the question is is Python on
the roadmap if so which quarter same
question for Scala so Python is actually
already being worked on right now we're
working on Python 3 support we plan on
supporting Python 3 we're debating
Python 2 right now if you have opinions
about supporting python 2 please let us
know on the cloud insiders mailing list
or through in-app feedback but yes
pythons on the roadmap my understanding
is it's going to ship within the next
two months I don't don't quote me on
that but that's that's my understanding
and that will be Python support for VMs
and containers so that includes the
Google compute engine google kubernetes
engine or VMs or containers running
elsewhere we're going to revisit the
support for App Engine standard coming
up soon we know that pythons incredibly
popular there as well same question for
Scala I'm not certain about that I'd say
I have to get back to you but I don't
actually know how to reach you but Scala
I don't know I know the debugger
supports Scala but I'm not certain if
profiler does or does not it is a it
ties in to the JVM via the agent
interface so I suspect it might just
work but I can't speak of confidence I
apologize the next question what's this
open census thing that I keep hearing
about how's that related to this how
does open tracing relate that's a very
good question so open census as I
mentioned during the presentation is an
instrumentation project for tracing and
for amplify metrics and tags that were
participating on of a number of other
vendors open census actually ties back
to a project at Google called census and
we probably could have gotten clever of
the open source name but whatever and
since this is automatically it's a
library that's automatically attached to
every job running on our job running at
Google so every container running at
Google that automatically captures
traces and metrics and performs the
appropriate correlations open census is
just are externalized version of this
we've been really successful internally
we want to bring those saved benefits to
the community and part of the reason
that we've we've just been participating
with other vendors is that tracing
instrumentation can be very difficult
one of the challenges of distributed
tracing is that you want to be able to
automatically propagate context so like
a trace ID for example from it from
incoming to outgoing requests and do
that across services this is somewhat
easier inside of a you know a company
like Google where we generally use the
same libraries and same api's but in the
external world this is challenging
because you need to support you know
every language that your developers use
so we tart
8:4 Oh consensus as well as every single
web framework RPC framework storage
library and so on so you can generate
both interesting traces or at a minimum
propagate context this becomes very
difficult it's very expensive for
vendors to do this which is why we
kicked off this effort with the
community and with other vendors to work
together on building these libraries and
to be clear open census is a set of
libraries so each library contains the
instrumentation so those hooks into web
frameworks storage clients etc contains
api's that you can use to manually
interact with traces of metrics and then
it contains exporters which will send
these back to you their stackdriver
or signal effects or whatever back-end
that you're using and so that's sort of
you know leading into this next question
about open trace and that's sort of the
big difference open tracing provides a
generalized API for interacting with
traces specifically open census provides
not just api's but instrumentation and
an implementation that allow developers
stock write on these the API is for open
tracing and open census are slightly
different for tracing it obviously open
census has many more api's for metrics
and stats and other things they differ
very slightly we've had some meetings
with the open tracing group about maybe
sort of alleviating that but at a
minimum I think we've already taken a
pull request that adds a sort of a
supplemental open open tracing API to
open census if you have any open tracing
instrumentation so if you've already
made investments in open tracing that'll
still work with open census all right
next question for profiler is there some
smart profiler concepts that highlights
likely problem areas ala ml for
inspection for a developer or a trained
production support engineer that is
another great question
so profiler as I mentioned is quite new
well we've been using it for some time
inside of Google it's only just reached
beta state I think two months ago for
external customers through stackdriver
profiler and so we're adding a ton of
features as we speak so if I think about
the concept of smart profiling we are I
talked about the weighted Prout
profiling during the demo and so what
this will do is is allow you to
or selectively your application when
it's run it's running into CPU or memory
problems so you'll get a more effective
flame graph out of that that you can use
to perform your own analysis and that's
really useful when you're when you're
investigating performance as a cost as
opposed to just general like cost
reduction and so that's a sort of smart
profiler concept that doesn't use ml
that we're adding to the product as we
speak if I think longer term there's a
lot of integrations we have planned
between stackdriver profiler and
stackdriver trace particular in
particular this will make tail latency
analysis really really powerful so
trying to reduce the latency in you know
the 90 95th percentile case or 99th
percentile case and when I think even
longer term that's when things like ml
come into the picture and it's certainly
not just for profiler but in general
just using ml on all the signals that we
collect whether those be traces metrics
profiles and so on
and so we will be making investments in
that and and we have some people already
thinking about this but profiler is in
an early enough state that we're mostly
focused on just adding features that
developers can use on their own rather
than you having a computer solve it for
them to identify places of poor
performance or identify areas where they
can improve the speed of their
application we have some other similar
really clever features coming to stack
driver trace so as I mentioned during
the presentation we do random sampling
for requests today and so this is useful
because it gives you a good profile the
latency of your app but one of the
challenges is that of course most of the
requests that you capture it might not
be interesting we're gonna switch that
pretty soon to do what we're calling
deferred sampling so we can sample based
on a cumulative latency or the presence
of errors which will also improve the
sampling for Trace much like we like I
mentioned we're investing in smart
profiling teacher features we're making
these investments to make tracing much
more powerful and effectively just a
smarter distributed tracing system and
those features are being added to the
open census project so that not just AK
driver but other vendors can benefit
from them as well next question I don't
use stackdriver today how hard is it to
get started with APM how long does it
take for my developers to go from 0 to
ready to debug that's a good question
so stackdriver is really really easy to
get started with
- clearly stackdriver a p.m. so today I
can actually speak to this very directly
as I instrumented the the sock drop
surface that you saw during the demo if
you're starting from scratch so you've
never used any kind of a PM or tracing
or profiling system before what you do
is you get the open census libraries you
link those to your app you get that one
for the correct language in most
languages that'll mean that once you do
that you'll get traces and applet all
metrics automatically in some languages
particularly Java you have to do a small
amount of work just to plumb through the
the correlation we have a lot of hooks
that make it easy but we can't do it
fully automatically particularly if
you're crossing thread boundaries so you
do a bit of work to get trace
correlation working even if you don't do
that you'll still get the metrics then
you can link the profiler and debugger
agents to your application so in Java
that's a Java agent that you put in your
Java bloch path and other languages
that's typically just a library you link
to your code in redeploy if you're
running on GCP for example if you're
running on GK as of this demo that's all
you need to do you don't need to supply
credentials or anything else we pick
those up automatically and so with you
know a few minutes of work you can get
most of these tools or if not all of
these tools working perfectly if you're
running on premises you'll need to
supply your service account credentials
which I think you can do by environment
variables or just fire if you can embed
them directly in your code you can do
that and then your APM instrumentation
will start responding back to us the the
second part of the question was how long
it'll take developers to go from zero to
ready to debug these tools are very
intuitive if you think of the UI that we
have for stackdriver trace or
stackdriver debugger this you know
debugger in particular we try and
emulate a you know a classic IDE
interface that you've used if you use
really any text editor but in particular
IntelliJ or Visual Studio which have
built-in debugging we try and emulate
that we found that for debugger like
engineers just get it almost instantly
it's it's exactly what they're used to
it works exactly as you would expect in
Yin there's no need to even attached to
particular instances so we found that
teams get ready are able to get started
for this really quickly we're doing a
lot of work later this year to better
integrate these products and so to
provide like a
single seamless UI where you can jump
between you know like traces errors
snapshots and so on that should make it
even easier for people to get started
but in its current implementation I
think stackdriver APM is pretty easy to
get started with alright so that wraps
up our list of questions I think we're
all done so thank you very much for
watching and I'll see you soon
goodbye
you